So an obvious better idea is just
what's referred to as Mean filtering.
Mean is my background now,
instead of just being the last frame,
which is really silly is just going to
be the average of the last end frames.
That's what it says here.
And my background at time t,
is just the average of the sum
of n frames in the past.
Okay?
In which case then my background my, my,
my mask is now I take my current image
subtract off that mean and
that is greater than the threshold.
Notice we now have a new parameter,
right?
We now have this parameter n.
We have to worry about
how much do we average?
So here's an example on the same
scene of using n as n equal 10.
All right, so it's average.
Now you'll see, it's,
it's kind of a weird thing, right.
So this, this van that has you're
kind of blended in there, right?
As it averages over different places and
my Foreground mask looks
kind of like this, all right?
And so I'm getting this
extension of the cars in,
in a variety of ways and
it's not so great.
And the reason that it's not so
great is that the average isn't
really the right thing, right?
So averaging over all those vans
is getting me this kind of weird thing,
right.
Now of course if I averaged over 50, you
know, but then I'd have all these other
cars coming through,
the average is very sensitive to this.
What you can think of is that, the
background is just sort of a constant
value, with maybe a little variation and
occasionally, I get some
random perturbation, right?
Some random noise comes along.
We've seen this before.
Remember when we were doing
noise filtering of images?
And we were using Gaussians, etc.,
and then we put in that like salt and
pepper noise.
And we said salt and pepper noise,
the problem with it is every now and
then you get this big spike in there.
And in average it'll get tweaked
around quite a bit by that.
So what was the solution to that?
The solution to that
was to use a median.